>>> NEARLY ONE YEAR AFTER THE
VOLENT AND WELL DOCUMENTED
ATTACK ON THE U.S. CAPITOL, SOME
PEOPLE ARE STILL DEFLECTING
BLAME FROM DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS AND ARE POINTING
FINGERS AT DEMOCRATS AND THE
FBI.
CNN'S DONIE O'SULLIVAN IS
JOINING US NOW FROM WASHINGTON.
DONIE, IT IS ASTOUNDING, WHAT
PEOPLE BELIEVE.
>> Reporter: YEAH, BRIANNA, EVER
SINCE THE CAPITOL ATTACK, THERE
HAS BEEN AN EFFORT, A CAMPAIGN,
TO ALTER, TO WARP AMERICANS'
UNDERSTANDINGS OF WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED HERE IN WASHINGTON ON
THAT DAY.
IN MANY WAYS, THAT
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN IS
WORKING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JANUARY 6TH ATTACK WAS NOT
THE REPUBLICANS NOR TRUMP.
IT WAS THE DEMOCRATS WERE BEHIND
IT ALL.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT CAUSED IT
ALL.
>> Reporter: DO YOU REALLY
BELIEVE THAT?
>> I KNOW IT.
AND THERE IS NO WAY THAT A
REPUBLICAN WOULD ACT THAT WAY.
AND THERE IS NO WAY THAT TRUMP
HAD ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH.
>> Reporter: WHAT ABOUT ALL THE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
CHARGED AND INDICTED?
>> BECAUSE IT'S ALL DEMOCRATIC
JUDGES AND PEOPLE THAT WERE ON
THE TAKE FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Reporter: IT'S BEEN A YEAR
SINCE THE ATTACK ON THE U.S.
CAPITOL.
>> THIS IS OUR CAPITOL!
>> Reporter: AND BECAUSE OF
DISINFORMATION, DENIAL, AND
DIVERSION, AMERICANS DON'T HAVE
A SHARED HISTORY, A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HAPPENED
HERE ON THAT DAY.
>> I THINK THE WHOLE REPORTING
OF IT IS A GIANT HOAX.
>> WE ARE VERY PEACEFUL PEOPLE.
IT WAS A SETUP TO ME.
IT WAS THE FBI HAD SET IT UP.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THEY WERE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS THAT DID THAT.
>> Reporter: YOU SAID THE WHOLE
THING IS A SETUP.
YOU DON'T REALLY BELIEVE THAT,
DO YOU?
>> I DO.
I DO.
BECAUSE TRUMP WON THE ELECTION.
THEY'VE PROVEN IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> Reporter: I REALLY DON'T
THINK TRUMP HAD MUCH TO DO,
OTHER THAN PEOPLE THAT WERE
SUPPORTERS MORE HIM SOMEWHERE
INVOLVED.
I THINKES ENTICED BY THE
FBI AND UNDERCOVER AGENTS.
>> Reporter: WHEN I SPOKE TO
TRUMP SUPPORTERS HERE IN
WASHINGTON ON JANUARY 6TH, MOST
WERE IN DENIAL ABOUT THE RESULTS
OF THE 2020 ELECTION.
DO YOU ACCEPT THAT BIDEN WON THE
ELECTION?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BIDEN DID NOT WIN THIS ELECTION.
>> Reporter: ON JANUARY 6TH, WE
WALKED WITH TRUMP SUPPORTERS WHO
MARCHED FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
WHERE TRUMP WAS DOING HIS
SPEECH, HERE TO THE U.S.
CAPITOL.
AS WE ARRIVED HERE, THAT IS WHEN
THE FIRST SECURITY BARRIER WAS
BREACHED.
AT THE TIME, SOME TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TOLD ME THEY WERE
HAPPY WITH WHAT HAPPENED HERE AT
THE CAPITOL.
ARE YOU PROUD OF WHAT HAPPENED
HERE TODAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE GONE ON
IN AND YANKED OUR SENATORS OUT
BY THE HAIR OF THE HEAD AND DRUG
THEM OUT AND SAID, "NO MORE."
>> I ABSOLUTELY STAND BEHIND
100% WHAT HAPPENED HERE TODAY.
1,000%.
IT'S TERRIBLE, HOW THIS ELECTION
WAS STOLEN.
>> Reporter: FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
HAVE CHARGED MORE THAN 700
PEOPLE IN CONNECTION WITH THE
CAPITOL RIOT AND REPEATEDLY
DOCUMENTED THE RIOTERS' SUPPORT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT SOME PEOPLE IN RIGHT-WING
MEDIA HAVE PUSHED THE DANGEROUS
IDEA THAT IT WAS ALL AN FBI
PLOT.
>> FBI OPERATIVES WERE
ORGANIZING THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
>> Reporter: THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER THAT THIS
WAS SOME KIND OF FALSE FLAG
EVENT STAGED BY THE DEMOCRATS OR
THE FBI.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO PEOPLE WHO
SAY JANUARY 6TH WAS THE BIGGEST
ATTACK ON AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR?
>> ABSOLUTE RUBBISH.
>> Reporter: AMID ALL THE DENIAL
AND DEFLECTION, I MET ONE TRUMP
SUPPORTER WHO SAID IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO BE REAL ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED ON THAT DAY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS THAT STORMED THE
CAPITOL?
>> YOU TALK ABOUT MIS-FOUND
FEELINGS.
SEEING THE FOLKS FROM MY SIDE OF
THE STATE THAT WERE THERE, AND
THEY'RE NOT THE PART OF THE
CAMPAIGN THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE.
>> Reporter: DO YOU THINK SOME
TRUMP SUPPORTERS THAT SAY IT'S
ANTIFA, IT'S BLACK LIVES MATTER,
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THAT'S BULL
SHIT BUT THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO
ADMIT IT?
IT'S EASIER TO BLAME SOMEONE
ELSE?
>> EVERYONE IS AFRAID TO, YOU
KNOW, TAKE THE BLAME.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, I THINK
THIS FAILURE TO LEARN FROM OR
EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6TH, ALONG WITH WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW, THIS SORT OF
CAMPAIGN TO GET ELECTION
DENIERS, TO MAKE THEM ELECTION
OFFICIALS, IT REALLY DOESN'T
BODE WELL FOR THE UPCOMING
MIDTERMS AND FOR FUTURE
ELECTIONS IN THIS COUNTR